finally I Walter a countdown genius will
be giving you all what do you want an
episode on Dexter's a boarder party
actually it's pronounced laboratory and
there's no need for your inferior
analysis Walter for I Heather the true
countdown genius well host this how many
times have I told you Dexter's Lab was a
definitive show for Cartoon Network in
the mid to late 90s - cartoon shorts
were produced for the what a cartoon
show in 1995 and 1996 which helped
launch the series creator and producer
genndy tartakovsky who later went on to
create Samurai Jack was the main
creative force behind the show however
he had what would become an all-star
animation team behind him Craig
McCracken
Seth MacFarlane Butch Hartman and many
others helped cultivate one of the most
well-received original series in Cartoon
Network's history over two seasons the
show aired 52 episodes and a TV movie
originally intended to end the series
before it was revived for 26 more
installments under a new team critical
acclaim and fan admiration continued to
endear dexter to new and old fans alike
when we look back on the series which of
the episodes usually divided into three
seven-minute segments are the most
memorable which of them cemented
Dexter's Lab as the quintessential
cartoon cartoon well it is my pleasure
to present the best of the best right
now
[Music]
number five you that's growth from
season two Dexter has had it with being
short he has to climb down from his bed
with a ladder sit on phone books to
reach the kitchen table and his parents
and sister are so much taller than him
they can sometimes barely hear him when
he speaks nonetheless he's excited to go
with his family to the carnival and ride
a new roller coaster called the thing
after a long wait the attendant notices
Dexter is too short to ride and thus he
is forced to wait as his family has all
the fun the boy genius then sets out on
a mission to make himself taller through
science so he can finally experience the
coaster for himself this episode may
have made me laugh the most out of all
of them the jokes and visual gags are
hilarious and a trademark of the show's
quality in those first two seasons
I love the episodes where Dexter
interacts with his family obviously he
does this regularly with DeeDee but when
we see their parents come into the mix
as part of the story it's always
entertaining Dexter's dad is especially
great do you think it's safe oh of
course honey there's no safer rides than
carnival rides his back and forth with
the line attendant is so quotable I love
it we're here to have family fun no sir
you don't understand the kid is too
little family fun child too small this
all leads to maybe the best ending to an
episode of Dexter's left I won't give it
away but the timing and payoff is
perfect you need to go back and watch
you that's growth it's a big old load of
family fun number four the big cheese
from season one
Dexter is supposed to be studying for
his French exam but keeps brushing it
off to work on more of his science
experiments by the end of the night he
decides on just listening to a recording
of basic French as he sleeps
unfortunately the record ends up
skipping and just repeats the same
phrase all night long when Dexter
awakens the next day those are the only
words he can speak no matter how hard he
tries however when he arrives at school
this ends up being less of a detriment
than he thought
this might very well be the most famous
episode of Dexter's Lab all due to these
words it's funny how this has become a
meme recently just goes to show how
well-known this episode still is among
those who watched it the Big Cheese is
basically an I am Groot situation as
voice actress Christine Cavanaugh got to
use different inflections on the same
phrase to portray different emotions
[Music]
which just as funny as Dexter delivery
is the reaction he gets from people
suddenly he has all the answers people
have wanted to hear their whole lives it
escalates it escalates to a great little
climax that was set up earlier in the
episode I'm alia du fromage maybe what
we all remember but Dee Dee's repeated
phrase is almost as funny and definitely
haunting towards the end this was a
genius premise storyboarded by Charlie
bean with background design by Butch
Hartman and directed by Tartakovsky
himself it's pretty much the classic
episode and if you haven't seen it in a
while what are you waiting for this big
cheese is just waiting for you to take
another cup number 3 dial M for monkey
wrestler from season 1 the imposing
cosmic being known only as wrath lor has
come to earth looking for a fight he
challenges our world's greatest heroes
to one-on-one battle if he is victorious
over them all he'll destroy the earth
many of the heroes fall in defeat but
there is one that's looking to give
wrestler a run for his money he's not
expecting the greatest hero of them all
[Music]
monkey before we get into rash lore
we've got to talk about monkey more
specifically his segment dial M for
monkey I loved when these would pop up
on the show as monkey was a really funny
and quite interesting character being
Dexter's pet he sneaks out when he has
to to defend the world as its mightiest
champion when he'd crossover with Dexter
centric episodes or interact with the
Justice friends it made this show feel
bigger there was more going on than just
Dexter and his lab which was a fun
concept for this kind of cartoon series
Randy Macho Man Savage voice traveler
with his unmistakable rasp eNOS he was a
blast to listen to in this role you have
been chosen to see the most glorious of
gifts
greatest strength and skill in fact I'd
say this role is right up there with his
turn as bone saw McGraw and the first
Sam Raimi spider-man movie he plays
wrestlers and fights superheroes and
both projects but I feel like he got to
go all-out crazy with his dial M for
monkey appearance it would have been fun
to see him pop up more as the series
went on but it never happened in any
case he was one of monkeys greatest foes
and this episode is one that I think
many fans still remember fondly to this
day
[Music]
[Applause]
number two the laughing from season two
at Dee Dee's birthday party Dexter is
bitten by the stray teeth of a clown
entertaining the group of children later
he starts acting strange and
involuntarily laughing as it turns out
Dexter transforms into a clown at night
and goes on a rampage of mischief
throughout the city
dee dee finds out about Dexter's
predicament and is the only one who can
save him from himself but you can't do
it alone she goes to a mime school to be
trained and soon enough its clown versus
my sister against brother but Dexter
sanity on the line
I love this episode it's interesting
it's creepy it's funny it hits the mark
in all the areas it aims to among other
well duh no ma jizz how didi reveals to
Dexter that he's been moonlighting as a
clown is kind of familiar the ending
battle with Dee Dee mind fighting Dexter
is fantastic the narration from the cops
just makes it that much better
that's a genuine mind yeah this concept
was a great one and played up to its
full potential in the laughing it also
had a little more time to do so as this
episode of Dexter's Lab had only two
segments instead of three check it out
for one of the most unique installments
in the series
Dexter's Lab has so many great episodes
it's ridiculous if some of your
favorites didn't fit onto the list odds
are I love them too but since we can't
have 200 honorable mentions here are a
few that just missed out on my top five
[Music]
in the number-one bet Dexter's
Laboratory episode is last but not beast
from season two Dexter is in Japan for a
foreign exchange program when he
accidentally awakens the monster but
extra soon all of Japan is in peril as
hero spanning the globe fight to stop
the rampage one by one they are defeated
by the Beast
the only hope is then dexter and his
family they pilot his multi formic
megabot and clashed with the monster to
stop him once and for all
last but not least is the only episode
in this series that has one continuous
story
it was meant as the finale before the
movie ego-trip and crossed over most of
the characters from the Justice friends
and dial M for monkey it's very well
done and would have been a worthy
send-off for the show the threat of bad
actor forcing Dexter's family to come
together like never before including
showing his parents his laboratory made
everything feel special and that song is
the best thing ever
I love it the conflict within and
outside of Dexter's family gave the
story a lot of heart which I really
appreciate
by the way tell me this isn't a
precursor to Samurai Jack long ago when
the world was young a mighty dragon
ravaged the land and destroyed villages
it devoured farms and crushed any
warrior bold enough to face it
throughout the first two seasons of the
series Dexter's Lab was one of the most
unique and imaginative cartoons on
television it was obviously influenced
by classics like looney tunes and early
hanna-barbera
but was also its own distinctive thing
it was great for kids but adults could
also enjoy the humor and situational
storytelling which is why it absolutely
holds up all these years later and if
you're ever feeling like revisiting the
Tartakovsky era of the show you won't be
disappointed for more Dexter's Lab
content head over to my personal Channel
and check out my review of ego trip is
the TV movie that was supposed to end
this series as good as we remember it to
be also my two favorite 90s Nickelodeon
and Cartoon Network shows go
head-to-head
it's Dexter's Laboratory versus Hey
Arnold going up soon at youtube.com
slash awesome Walter I want to hear what
the you guys what is your favorite Star
slam episode what do you want to see us
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let us know keep it in a taut you
can follow me on the facebook a follow
along on Twitter and you can find me on
Twitter Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday night well catch you next week
back here for a brand new episode of 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you